whether or not Johan understands this is
where we're living because he can't go
to the United States without me and if I
don't want to go I don't want to go
America
did she really just say that 90 Day
Fiance the other way is back and on top
of Danielle crushing johann's American
Dream which rubs me the wrong way we
also get to know Gabe the franchise's
first transgender male and he comes in
hard boom you have a bulge right there
plus there are a few must-see moments
that have me thinking wow this person is
getting scammed used played whatever you
want to call it basically we're running
through all my first impressions of
these couples and the family members
attempting to support them on this
unique Journey when Chris told me that
she was going to go to Columbia and
marry a lady what was really kind of a
big surprise all at one time to me I'm a
devout member of the church but I
believe it's not our place to judge it's
Heavenly father's place to judge
she's been through a lot of things
and I hope this will bring her happiness
that's love let's get into it
[Music]
fans fam it's melicia with every new
season especially with new cast members
just to be real I know it takes us a
minute to care to actually get into
their story lines but if you are going
to go on this wild adventure with me
this time around there are a few things
that went down during the season for
Premiere episode that we need to talk
about first let's kick things off with a
cast member that has me the most
concerned to say the least I'm Jen and
I'm 46 years old and I live in Stillwell
Oklahoma
Jen lives on her family's farm with her
mom and her brother and she's engaged to
32 year old Rishi who lives in India I
have a track record of falling for the
wrong guys
I would choose guys who were good
looking and very charismatic but in
terms of the long-term partner they were
not what I needed Jen matarishi on a
trip to India in the hotel lobby and she
claims I'm assuming because of her past
she wasn't that into him at first do
that again but the more time they spent
together on that trip the more she came
around and a month later he proposed of
course he did Jen said yes but she
admits she's not sure why it's hard to
pinpoint exactly what made me fall
horishi
but I don't know I just
I knew he was the one it was completely
out of the blue we hadn't discussed the
future we hadn't discussed me leaving or
staying or anything like that
but I did not hesitate at all before
saying yes it just felt right boy if I
did everything that felt right
and just the fact that he proposed
without them talking about the future
in my opinion that's a red flag we
hadn't discussed the future we hadn't
discussed me leaving or staying or
anything like that it's not romantic
it's irresponsible
hold yourself
yeah very good when it comes to Rishi he
apparently has a law degree and a
master's degree but at some point he
discovered personal training and
modeling is his passion being a model
and a fitness trainer I have a lot of
attention from the woman
feeling exhausted yeah
I don't need to give any effort they
approach themselves to speak with me
swing
you mean pose
I nailed it and oh yeah he's obsessed
with his hair I love my hair I'm the
only one here in my city who has a long
hair with the girl
it's my image basically
some people say that I'm look like an
Indian Jesus
[Music]
are you starting to see why I'm a little
bit concerned here
okay in cases like this I would love to
know who applied to be on the show Rishi
or Jin it can say a lot anywho after not
seeing Rishi for two years due to covid
jyn is preparing to move to India in a
week even though she spent about 45 days
with him in total
that is 90 day for you don't act like
you don't know and based off the season
trailer I'm wondering if Rishi has any
real intention of marrying Jen I'm damn
sure David foursome for the arrangements
they are looking already
they were in talk they were not
confirmed I just keep saying over and
over just be honest with me
Rishi what would Jesus do okay bad joke
moving on some people say that I'm look
like an Indian Jesus let's get into
Danielle a 42 year old high school
history teacher and yoga instructor in
New York City she's married to 32 year
old Johan but he lives in the Dominican
Republic where they met he was a
personal trainer at the hotel that I was
staying at
and he was absolutely beautiful I'm not
gonna lie Johan would have caught my eye
too now these two aren't new to the
90-day Universe they were part of the
love in Paradise spin-off but I know
half of y'all didn't watch that show and
it's all good because honestly I didn't
either so a quick ketchup after knowing
each other for only five months and
spending a total of three weeks together
Danielle and Johann tied the knot and in
the years since they've been living
separately until now because Danielle
has decided to pack her bags and move
down to the Dr and build a life with her
man I feel like New York is a toxic
boyfriend
you can't get away from him you love him
so much
but you know that he's making your life
worse
wow what an analogy this episode
Danielle returns to the Dominican
Republic to look at apartments before
her big move but there is a problem
Johan has no clue that Danielle is
planning to permanently move to the
Caribbean a place he's trying to leave
so he can create a better life for
himself he really wants to come to New
York he doesn't want to stay here I
would prefer to come here
another
[Music]
dominicano quiere
and yeah this is giving me Vibes that
Johan is using Danielle at least just a
little bit Johan doesn't even take his
wallet out if I'm around he just expects
that if we buy something I'm going to
pay for it it's something even one of
her yoga students brought up I'm afraid
that he's a sunky monkey
a funky Panky is a man who works at a
resort and is looking for tourists to
come and you know provide them with
money and goods and visas and take care
of them and their families so that's my
biggest fear
I'm starting to wonder if it's
Danielle's too we have to find an
apartment is like the most important
thing to me
I have to somehow explain to Johan that
we're never going to New York
we have a lot to do
more in case it wasn't clear Johann is
still working on his English so he had
no clue what she just said anyway once
they get rolling in the car Danielle
confirms Johan's worst fear she doesn't
want to go back to the U.S ever
and then she just straight up crushes I
can't say what I want to say but she she
Stomps on The American Dream all because
of her experience in New York as if New
York is the only place to live in
America mi amor
ous estupido
escochami
mi casa cuatro Mio dolares
necesito insurance for total as Danielle
complains about New York being expensive
which I think we all can agree is true
she also doesn't seem to take into
account the realities of life in the
Dominican Republic Johann tries to tell
her that people work hard for years just
to earn enough to live day by day
whether or not Johan understands this is
where we're living
because he can't go to the United States
without me and if I don't want to go I
don't want to go
America
personally I think what she said is
messed up for one I don't think it's
right to kill someone else's dream
because of your negative experience
scammer or not and two it's clearly not
the truth the American dream is real
this country is not perfect by far but
people have come here and built
something out of nothing Danielle might
really be over New York but I'm
wondering if her wanting to live in the
Dr for good is more about proving to
herself or maybe the world that Johan is
not using her for a Visa
just a thought all right next up Gabriel
from Florida and Isabelle from Colombia
as I mentioned before Gabe's making
franchise history as the first
transgender star and he owns this
business which if I'm to be honest took
me by surprise at first I was like he's
making what muchas penises you can see
it's already starting to puff up I
created a brand it is underwear that
already have a bulge in them
you have a bulge right there but that's
why having an open mind is so important
because what some might view as a joke
is a solution to a real problem people
experience he hit an entrepreneurship
gold mine with this idea he filled a
need I created a brand called get more
proudware it is underwear for female to
male transgender people who have not had
their bottom surgery yet
which is swapping out what genitalia you
have if you're a trans guy just knowing
that there's nothing there and there's
nothing under it's
it's it sucks
so trans person female to male they have
to wear a packer which is like a fake
limp penis and then they have to wear a
harness to hold it in place and then
they have to put their underwear on and
that is a lot of work and it's heavy
Gabe explains that he came up with the
idea after this embarrassing moment
Packers fall out your pants
one day when I was younger I was
actually swimming and lo and behold
guess what I'm swimming this way and my
sock is swimming that way and I'm like
oh crap so I'm just like oh that's not
mine I'm like uh no we're not doing this
today or so home says quote more power
to him and this might be good
advertising for his business as well
great Point Aura more eyes means more
money and in this case more confident
people in the world and for those of you
who might be struggling with the idea of
this something I'm learning in life
overall is that there are some things
that you are never going to fully
understand and it's important to have
enough humility to make peace with that
it's a very hard life being trans
[Music]
it's not like one day you just wake up
and you're like oh you know what I'm
trans no it's a feeling that you feel
your entire life Gabe goes on to open up
about his personal Journey when I was
younger I want to say in kindergarten my
cousin had a friend that dressed like a
boy
once I found out that you know girls can
wear boy clothes I started with
basketball shorts and I just wear
basketball shorts every single day
when I was 16 years old I came out as
lesbian
because I didn't know that you can
change your gender I didn't know
anything like that all I know is oh I
feel like a boy but you know what I date
girls oh I'm like when I was little
that's what I just thought it was you
know in his early 20s Gabe learned about
transitioning and he made it happen I'm
trans once upon a time I was a girl and
now I'm a whole man
a whole man because I already got my
surgery
and when it comes to his love life
Gabe's business took him to Colombia
where he was looking for a supplier
that's when he met Isabel I was like
damn girl she fine like she is so
beautiful like I'm like ah like my heart
is like melting
we definitely had immediate chemistry
Isabelle
is first night
thing but the next morning Gabe knew he
had to tell her that he is transgender
and here was her response so I ended up
telling her through text messages
and she tells me it's okay because I
just see you as a man
[Music]
point I was like oh yes like this is
like it could have worked out in my
favor like any better yeah
look I'm not too well versed on this
topic so I'm not going to speak much
about it but I have heard stories where
people find themselves in situations
that turn out to be the complete
opposite not to be a Debbie Downer but
in some cases people have lost their
lives when they chose to speak out about
their truth so yes Gabe is lucky to have
found Isabel and they have been together
for over a year now I'm just hoping she
has his best interests at heart a couple
months after we met I started renting
apartment in Medellin Colombia
and this one has been moved out of her
family's house and in with me and
managing I've been going back and forth
ever since but now I'm gonna move there
permanently and I'm proposing to her
because I cannot be away from this woman
our shocker some red flags here
according to Gabe's sister he doesn't
make the best decisions when it comes to
dating she says he's impulsive mind you
she's saying this as he gets a tattoo of
Isabelle's name
are you going to get rid of the other
girlfriend's name or the other name yes
we're gonna black it out Malcolm said
he'll black out the Ning for me
this is very much Gabe you fall in love
after a week and then boom you're living
with someone you're tattooing their name
on you how many girlfriends do I live
with you've lived with what like two or
three but then you also but then you
also move them into our mom's house
oh she is telling all his business then
Gabe's sister gets blunt Gabe moving to
Colombia
to be with a woman is a stupid decision
he has a tendency to jump the gun and
rush into things it can get exhausting
clearly she sounds tired of it for sure
and so what about her kids you said that
you didn't want to date someone with
kids after your last relationship you
thought you would never do it again
yeah but her kids are big
16 and 11. okay so it's they take care
of themselves so what does that mean
just disregard them no it means that I
don't have to like babysit them you
don't want to help her with her kids
is that what you're saying I'm not
saying that I'm not gonna of course I'm
gonna help her because like we all live
together but I'm saying that she's
motherly improvised for her children
but you pay the bills
yeah so who's providing
if I have some tea I would sip it snap
snap Gabe's sister is not playing she
came through and had to remind him of a
few things after that reality check she
did soften up and let him know that
she's going to miss him
course obviously I love you I want the
best for you I love you too if if it
doesn't work out I'll be I'll be here
and you can say I told you so
allowing family to learn hard lessons on
their own is tough hopefully Gabe and
Isabelle prove her wrong though since
we're on the topic of family members
doing their best to support the 90 day
newbies I want to quickly chat about
this touching moment between Chris and
her mom before we wrap things up my name
is Chris from Haleyville Alabama
um 40 going on 20 because that's how I
feel I feel like I'm 20. and I look like
it too
Chris a mother of two is a free spirit
and she's moving to Colombia in a week
to be with her girlfriend Jamie who
she's never met in person
mm-hmm yeah they met online and this is
Chris's first serious same-sex
relationship I've only had a couple of
relationships with females
I don't really call them relationships
we were intimate it was just that
I never went out in public with them
because it was embedded in me at a very
young age you know this is wrong this is
wrong and
my fear kept me miserable for years and
I'm finally happy and I would not change
it for anything
all right now that you know her
backstory I want to show you what really
impressed me Chris was talking to her
mom about her move and when the producer
asks her mom how she feels about Chris
having a relationship with another woman
considering they live in what's viewed
as the Bible Belt she says this when
Chris told me that she was going to go
to Columbia and marry a lady what was
really kind of a big surprise all at one
time to me
she never brought a lady home to meet me
never spoke of it at all
I'm a devout member of the church
but I believe it's not our place to
judge it's Heavenly father's place to
judge
she's been through a lot of things
and I hope this will bring her happiness
for me that was such an unexpected and
refreshing response it goes back to what
I mentioned earlier about being okay
with not understanding or even agreeing
with certain things but having enough
humility to say I don't know it all but
I do know that I'm going to lead with
love that is what's in my control how
someone else chooses to live their life
is not after all the majority of us are
out here just trying to do our best
all right well there is a couple I was
hoping we would meet in the first
episode but I guess we have to wait
Debbie who was 43 years older than her
Moroccan boyfriend Osama I am looking
forward to hearing their love story
you're you're creepy man I'm creepy I'm
bad I'm ugly
I'm son of [__] okay
he took my trust and he urinated all
over it I'm ashamed of you you're weak
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with E.T because we are covering
it all I will see you next time
foreign